Getting from B1 one to B2 is
the hardest, longest part of
my language learning journey.
Hi there, Steve Kaufmann here and
today I want to talk about the inverted
hockey stick and language learning.
So before we get into it, remember if
you enjoy these videos, please subscribe,
click on the bell for notifications.
And if you follow me on a podcast
service, please leave a comment.
I do appreciate it.
So what is the inverted hockey
stick and why am I talking about it?
Well, let me briefly introduce this idea.
It's, it's an image
that I have used before.
And the idea is that if you know what
a hockey stick looks like, normally
you've got a long shaft and a blade.
If you inverted or turn it
upside down, you've not got this
blade that goes up like this.
And then a long shaft.
And when we learn a language, we begin
by making, although it's very steep
and we're struggling very hard, but we
actually do make fairly rapid progress.
We learned some words, we understand some
words, we can use some words we think wow.
And then pretty soon though,
we are no longer in this steep
climb where we're learning a lot
or think we're learning a lot.
We now discover that it's a very
long road before we achieve, you
know, what we want to achieve, which
is fluency, understanding movies,
being able to converse with people.
It's an awfully long road and they, the
progress is, is, is actually quite slow.
And that's one of the dilemmas in
language learning is, is to keep
yourself motivated during that long, slow
period that shaft of the hockey stick.
So why do I bring this up now?
Because the other day, my son,
uh, because normally we don't go
to the office so much anymore.
And so the mail comes to my home, but
some mail does go to the office and
he brings home this, uh, very neatly
wrapped package from the US from an
R Rogers, uh, in Lansing, Michigan.
And there's actually a pretty
steep postal charge there, $22.
And it's addressed to me at my office.
And I'm saying, gee, what is this?
I don't know an R Rogers and
it's very neatly wrapped.
And so then, uh, inside it
is this neat package here.
Uh, and then as I open it and you
hear a noise, it's got a very neat
use of a Home Depot, a box, and lo
and behold, I find a hockey stick.
Okay.
Now this hockey stick is for short people
because actually in real life, the shaft
is much, much, much longer as the, a
path to learning languages as longer.
But, and it has, uh, a letter here.
Hi, Steve, a fan of LingQ and
your YouTube channel here.
I thought you could use a model inverted
hockey stick with a few pointers
maybe as language level indicators
to conveniently demonstrate...
and these are...
Are these different  colored pointers?
This is unbelievable.
All the best in conveying, conveying and
appreciation for language learning to your
channel subscribers and LingQ members,
Russ a fan from Lansing, Michigan.
Okay.
Russ, thank you very, very much.
And you know, aside from the fact
that it illustrates the hockey stick,
anyone has ever considered learning
languages the community of language
learners is so mutually supportive.
I mean, Russ has, is extremely
supportive and, and, um, you know,
helpful and, and encouraging and stuff.
But so many language their nerves
are when I go to the polyglot
gatherings, everybody is so supportive.
No one criticizes anyone's
level in the language and
everybody wants to help everyone.
There's this great helpfulness in
this community of language learners.
So let's have a look at what we have here.
So this is, uh, the inverted hockey stick.
And, uh, so let's say that
we have different colors.
So when you are really doing well,
you know, you are basically green,
you know, the light is green.
I think that's what probably what
Russ had in mind and maybe that's
C1, which is for all intents and
purposes, you're flying in the language.
B2, which I consider to be my goal,
in other words, and for those of
you who aren't familiar with the
European framework, I mean, B2
means that you're comfortable.
You make a lot of mistakes.
C1 means you're really very good.
You make few or very few mistakes, C1.
C2 is like you're as fluent
as a native basically.
So, so then, well, let's get, make
that, see one yellow is when I
approach a traffic light, if it's
yellow, I'll tend to stop, which
is what you're supposed to do.
A lot of people just go flying through it.
They speed up when they
see a yellow light.
So let's say that when you're in the
B area, uh, B1 B2, you shouldn't,
even though you're encountering
difficulties, you should speed up.
Like the guys that run
yellow lights the same.
Just go for it.
Run that yellow light.
Now, when you're here, now it,
you know, as I'm doing this, I
was thinking to myself, maybe I
should have made the shaft okay?
Maybe I should've put green colors there.
Uh, but I've started this way so I'm
gonna, I'm going to stay with it.
So here with Russell's hockey stick,
well, you start at the beginning of the
shaft it's as if your can't move at first
because you, the language makes no sense.
It's just noise.
Uh, but very quickly you start
to gain a bit of a sense of
the language, but it's still a
struggle, but it's a steep struggle.
And because it's as if you're, if
you're climbing a cliff and you're
kind of getting a toehold and you're,
you're actually moving quite a
distance up, even though it's hard
work, it's hard work on your legs.
I don't know why I would go for...
maybe I should change it, maybe I should.
Maybe I should uh, but, but
I don't want you to stop.
Uh, when you're at C1.
Okay?
So let's say that it's red because
there are barriers, but you're going
to break through the barriers and
you're going to break through the
barriers as you climb that steep initial
period, uh, in learning a language.
But then as you hit the shaft of the
hockey stick, now you're in that middle
period, B1 B1 - B2, I guess this would
be, but I should move this up here
because I think B2 and C1 is so close
that I can't really tell the difference.
And C2 is almost an unattainable.
You know, if you get that, that's fine.
You really have to focus on
that language in great depth to
achieve that B1 or at least B2 C1
are both good goals to achieve.
Maybe that's where, you
know, you run, you run the...
trouble is the traffic light
doesn't turn green, it turns red.
And so if you run, if you try to run
that yellow light and it turns red and
there's a cop there you're in trouble.
So that's not very realistic.
So maybe I should have
done it the other way.
Anyway, doesn't matter.
The principle is when you start
in the language, it's all noise.
You work very hard.
I listen many, many times in this.
Uh, content, then I move on to
this shaft of the hockey stick,
slow, slow, slow progress.
Actually, I should move this up here
because I think that getting from getting
from a B1 to B2 is the hardest, longest
part of my language learning journey.
Once I'm at B2 where I can understand
stuff, I can understand movies
I don't care if I make mistakes.
I don't care if there's words that I
don't know, because there's so many
things I can do in the language.
So I will, at some point,
maybe I've moved to C1.
Maybe I'd have to take a test to
prove that I'm at C1, but either
at B2 or C1, I'm comfortable.
And as I said, this other C2
is just out of the picture,
except for the real diehards.
The difficulty is here when
we get to the top of the steep
climb high-frequency words were
encountering over and over again.
We're acquiring these words.
We think we're making progress
and we turn the corner.
And we're in this area here where it
seems like we can't remember anything.
Uh, we're not very satisfied
with our improvement anymore.
And that's where you gotta put your
foot on the gas pedal, run that yellow
light and take yourself up to B2.
And once you had B2, you can
progress as much as you want.
It depends on how much opportunity
you have to speak the language,
if you live in the country, a
whole bunch of things like that.
So thank you very much, Russ, from
Lansing, Michigan, uh, I don't know
how you intended your, uh, inverted
hockey stick to be used, but I very
much appreciate you sending this to me.
And so I wanted to share it with
my viewers and also to thank you.
And I will be sending Russ a note
and I will also leave you with, uh,
previous videos that I've done on this
issue of the hockey stick, the inverted
hockey stick and how we get through
the doldrums, that long period, when
we think we're not making any progress.
Thank you for listening.
Bye for now.